[music] Facade of City Hall
City Hall Park
just off Broadway the Brooklyn Bridge
where Steve Brodie took a dare and
jumped, behind it the Manhattan Bridge;
his business is picking up,
speaking of business, Wall Street from
Broadway the Exchange,
Subtreasury Building, scene of
Washington's Inauguration and historic
Trinity Church;
here, Old New York's elite worship, and
many lie buried,
Alexander Hamilton
Robert Fulton Photo imprint,
Street sign Bowling Gr & Broadway
New York's first park, Bowling Green,
still enclosed by the original iron
fence imported from England in 1771
Abraham de Peyster, mayor of New York in
1691; the Custom House,
seen from it a labyrinth of brick
granite and marble.
Surrounding Bowling Green is the oldest
neighborhood in Manhattan now a monument
to national and international finance,
No 1 Broadway, once General
Washington's headquarters now
headquarters for great shipping lines.
Looking south from The Battery, the
Statue of Liberty symbol of America as
Broadway is the symbol of Main Street
CU of face of Statue of Liberty